So, welcome back. So, in the last half we have discussed that how to summarize the data
in a descriptive format which is a mere summarization. It cannot capture the whole feature of the
data. Two of the dataset might have the same summary variables but there might be inherent
features are different for different datasets. So, one step ahead to capture all the features
of the data is through the empirical distribution function which is very easy to construct but
it has a very nice feature. The empirical distribution function f and t which is may
counting how many observations are there in the sample which are less than equals to t
divided by the total number of observations which in a sophisticated notation you can
write that indicator variable x i less than equal to t. So, this I mean bold 1 x i less
than equal to t can take either value 0 or 1. So, it will scan on all x i values, it
will check whether it is less than equal to t or not less than equal to t. If the condition
satisfied x i less than equal to t it will consider one otherwise 0. So, it is a sum
of the string binary string either 0 or 1 and ultimately we divide the thing by n so
it is the average. So, depending on this number you can see that if you take that value of
t very very less I mean like going to minus infinity this number will be definitely 0
and if you take a very large value of t then this number is going to be 1. So, that within
that restriction which is the feature of probability, probability always lying between 0 and 1
you can have this step function where if you consider very less number of observations
10 observations then it is a jump over different locations where the data are jump amount
of jump is everywhere 1 upon n wherever there is a data there is a jump and the jump amount
is 1 upon n. So, and the entire graph is going from 0 to 1.
Now, if you increase the sample size the red graph becomes the green one the more finer
jump 1 upon 100, but that also have the same feature it is going from 0 to 1 non decreasing
way and if you make it 10000 then you can see that you get the blue graph and this blue
graph is almost overlapping on the true graph which is the black one. So, what you can visualize
that this simple function will approximate the probability as n goes to infinity.
So, if you have a large sample the probabilistic feature of the data that means how many observations
less than equal to a certain number that is very nicely and tightly captured by this empirical
distribution function. So, every time we if you want to check say within say a to b within
a to b within a to b may be say here a equal to 0.1 to here it is say 1 within this range
how many how much probability is there. So, theoretically it should be the height
cap based on the black graph. So, height cap based on the black graph, but from the data
itself if you consider the blue one then from this number of the blue graph to this number
of the blue graph that much gap is good enough to estimate how many observations are here
and that can be done for any value a and b. So, this is how probabilistic structure of
the data can be very easily computed from the given data set.
Now let us move on for this mile per gallon data set of the car data if you consider the
number based on the number of cylinders. So, there are three categories of cars with
4 cylinders, 6 cylinder and 8 cylinder. The proportionate value for 4 cylinder is 3.37
something for 6 cylinder is 2.2187 and 8 cylinder is 0.475. So, if you want to construct
empirical CDF from that data. So, this one. So, before any below 4 everything 0 at 4 there
is a jump and this amount of jump is same as this one. So, this the next amount of jump
is the value associated to this one and the final jump is the largest jump. So, that value
is associated to this one. So, empirical CDF is a step function by construction and it
is continuous from this side. So, if you approach from top or the right it is continuous in
this way, but here the jump discontinuity is happening.
You can have another categorization whether it is manual or automated. So, if we consider
manual here and the automated here. So, binary classification of the data either it is manually
operated or automatic operated. So, then also the proportional deviation gives you another
empirical CDF and these are the data for discrete valued random variable.
Now, if you want to see the continuous valued structure for the all 32 observations at the
mile per gallon, if you want to calculate the empirical CDF function it will be looking
like this. So, this one I have not described here so that part I am not considering. So,
is this information transferable in a summarized form? Look whatever we are doing here we need
to track all of the data point and the jump. So, that also it is summarizing whatever we
are willing to summarize, but it computational cost or the if you want to see everything
in terms of the knowledge transfer or the information transferring it is same as the
entire data set nothing summarized as such. So, the next way of summarization that we
are invoking here is based on the probability distribution function which is a theoretical
version of the empirical CDF. So, why not the graph that we are seeing we will have
a smooth approximation of that and that smooth approximation will be easily transferable
information for us. So, in that case if we have a theoretical object which is a function
capital F which is moving from real number to 0 to 1 because it is a probability and
it will capture the probability capital X less than equal to small x or x belongs to
minus infinity to x for any real number x and that is known as the cumulative distribution
function. So, here we have a very easy toy example suppose
you roll on two dice and consider the sum of the phase values. So, the values can be
between 2 to 12. So, it can be 1 1. So, it is 2 and it can be at most 6 6. So, it is
12. So, if you consider that experiment. So, from here very easily you can see that all
possible combinations we have 2 to 12 all the probabilities are assigned here this part
we will call later on at as a probability mass function or probability density function.
But on the other hand the right hand side whatever you are seeing nothing but the CDF
as it is a discrete value random variable this empirical CDF is almost looking like
the the usual CDF. But for continuous valued random variable I am coming with the example
first. So, for continuous valued random variable if this the smooth curve is the CDF and the
contribution from different segment of the data the green part is contributing here the
dark yellow part is contributing here the blue part is contributing from here to here
the purple or the pink part is contributing from here to here and then again yellow is
here and then the gray in the top one. So, this change is a very gradual change and now
we are trying to track back. So, first try to see how we are approaching we are approaching
from the data from the any data set we can always construct the empirical CDF.
Now if we have an empirical CDF can we have an approximation of that function if it is
a discrete valued random variable nothing to be approximated. If it is a continuous
valued random variable we have we are willing to have an approximation for that one maintaining
a certain thing like this that if I integrate or some one function I will get the CDF and
this function is a non-negative function if I integrate that one over the range I will
get the CDF. So, this this function either in this integration form or in the summation
form it is known as the probability density function.
So, if it is discrete it is in terms of the summation if it is continuous it is in terms
of the integration not a big deal that one, but the advantage of this. So, if you if we
consider from this diagram A to diagram B. So, the first jump is of amount this the second
jump is of amount this and so on and so forth. So, this is how if you consider the sum of
the height of the first pillar and second pillar you will you are supposed to reach
here and second pillar third pillar fourth pillar you are supposed to reach here. So,
in that way PDF and PMF for discrete value random sorry CDF and PMF of the discrete
value random variables are associated with it.
On the other hand if you have the continuous value random variable. So, this is the PDF
of standard normal normal 0 1s and distribution if you integrate this function you will get
this CDF this CDF often might not have a closed form. So, the construction of the PDF from
the data is nothing but a back calculation back calculation in the way if you have a
smooth approximation for the CDF curve FX get a derivative it will give you the PDF
or in the other hand you have the histogram you smooth it out whatever may be the way
integration minor that thing sorry FX you will get. So, either we do the approximation
here or we do the approximation here. So, this is the fundamental structure of obtaining
a probabilistic characterization of a distribution from the data whatever textbook distribution
that you see from say normal gamma weibull log normal everything is originated through
the approximation of the real data with a known function which is easy to deal with nothing
extra has been done then there are certain property of transformation which can give
the genesis of the other from the old one that is a separate mathematical construction.
But inherently starting from this normal distribution it is always or the scientist always has tried
to do that you approximate the histogram with a known function which is a non-negative function
very nicely easily integrable function and you integrate that function you will get the
probability distribution that is how the thing works it is simply a back calculation.
Now, we are moving another aspect which is a which is the linear algebra part. So, next
day we will combine this probabilistic approach and the linear algebra part whatever we are
going to discuss now together and we will discuss multivariate structure as well as
at its estimation and application part ok. So, the thing why we are going to introduce
you this vector structure because we will not only discuss about only one variable whatever
we have studied so far often we will have more than one variables together and as a
consequence we need to hold all the data together we have to analyze all the data together ok.
So, it is not a component wise analysis can lead us to the correct information we have
to analyze more than one variables together and for that we need some matrix algebra very
basic matrix algebra not a advanced one. So, we consider the vector addition. So, here
vector by vector we mean a component which or a mathematical object which has more than
one component. So, typically this u is a vector if you multiply a constant with u you will
get another vector v is another vector you multiply another constant you will get another
vector. So, it is eventually scaling A, U, B, V they are the scaling of the value of
U in with different magnitude after that if you add them. So, that is nothing but vector
addition that you have learned from long back I hope it will help you to revise and visualize
the thing. So, depending on the vector itself it has a magnitude and a direction as simple
as that and then again scaling to the vector it inflates or shrinks the magnitude then
after that you will do the addition. Then what mathematically we get we get a linear
combination linear combination. So, linear combination how it is important or applicable
to us because we are willing to get information from the data.
So, how we give the weightage to different features that is important. So, giving weightage
to different features it can be done only through linear combination the name can be
differently used in different subjects, but mathematically it is known as the if people
also call it is a weighted average yes this is true the linear combination weighted average
is a special case of linear combination. So, linear combination is the more general
structure you can do many thing taking average requires some restriction on the weight.
So, the important aspect that it is also because addition is commutative the linear combination
is also commutative in this structure. Scalar multiplication to a vector is turn by turn
multiplication. If I multiply alpha to a vector each component of a vector is multiplied.
Now, let us come to the and this will consider all possible applications like sum of the
vector sum of the vector very easily you can observe this is it. Suppose if I want to write
sum over xi I run from 1 to n which I can write 1 vector transpose x vector where x vector
is x 1 x 2 x n whole transpose and 1 vector is all component 1 whole transpose. So, as
a consequence this entire thing we can combine together which is nothing but 1 vector dot
product x vector. So, sum you can write in this way average if you want to take average
or sample mean that is 1 upon n 1 upon n 1 upon n which is x power. So, vector representation
makes the thing much more easier. Now, let us variable selection how can you do? Suppose
I want to choose 3 variables out of or 2 variables out of 3 variables. So, say for example if
I have a matrix with 3 variables that is the example will be of matrix multiplication as
well. So, say for example I have 3 variables first variable x 1 second variable x 2 third
variable. So, 3 feature vectors I have. So, x 1 1 x 1 2 x 1 n sorry I should write in
may be x11, x21, xn1, x second column, 1, 2, x22, xn2, x13, x23, xn3. So suppose this
is a matrix of feature vector and the matrix has dimension n cross 3. I am not willing
to take all the feature vector, I am willing to take only the first feature vector and
the third feature vector.
Now what I need at the end is the outcome as n such observation with two components.
So here I need to multiply with another matrix which is again 3 cross 2. So 3 cross 2 how
can we construct? The first feature vector I am looking for 1, second feature vector
I do not want, third feature vector I do not want. Then the next feature vector what I
want is the third one. So first feature vector I do not want, second feature vector I do
not want, third one I want. So if you multiply now you will get x11 will come, x21 will
come and xn1 will come. Similarly, x13 will come, x23 will come, xn3 will come. So deliberately
we can remove the second column. But it is not necessary that we will have such a easy
construction that only one feature vector I will be extracting out. We might have instead
of 3 we might have 30,000 feature vectors and may be say 200 we are willing to extract
from there or we are willing to have a linear combination of all of them.
So I need to combine, I can have a vector here which will give the linear combination
of all of the features and it will construct another one. So this thing will be applicable
for say principal component regression or even principal component analysis itself variable
selection. So all this stuff you can do with the matrix multiplication. And matrix multiplication
eventually happening row multiplied with column and that is the thing what we have
just mathematically written here matrix multiplication as well as well as their addition, subtraction
I hope this is pretty simple for you. Addition if we do for a matrix then it is term by term
addition or subtraction. If we do matrix multiplication then definitely we go for this
way the row and column interaction whatever we have. Now another important aspect is block
matrix, block matrix eventually splits the entire matrix into say in this way 4 or even
more than that blocks. Now block matrix product can follow this structure but where the block
matrix is important definitely variable selection is one important aspect because we need not
require all the feature vectors often.
Another important aspect is if we are willing to predict a subset of vector given the other
subset of vector. So suppose the x vector has component x1, x2, xk, xk+1 up to xn.
Now given the value of xk+1 up to xn I am willing to predict the value of this part.
It is in that case the application of this block matrix or the inversion of this block
matrix will be very much useful. This is a very genuine problem because we may not always
require to predict only one value. We may require to predict more than one values together
which is often important for image classification and the predictive value of or classification
of the image and the prediction of the image.
Next transpose by operation it is very easy for understanding. So each row becomes column.
So whatever is the first row here that becomes the first column here where the second row
that is the second column and third row is the third column. By construction it is very
simple but by application it is important because most of the cases when we are dealing
with regression problem we have the number of observation is much more compared to the
number of feature vector. And as a consequence the matrix or the linear system of equations
that we need to solve there the number of variables present is comparatively less compared
to the number of observation or the number of equation.
And then you come up with a matrix which is something like this that this is x matrix
feature matrix then beta vector and then y vector which is the response vector well added
some error but you notice that this is n cross say k plus 1 or if there are k features then
it is n cross k plus 1 and in this case n is much much larger than k. And as long as
it is a square it is a rectangular matrix you have no scope to invert it.
And the beta vector beta vector is an element from it is a k plus 1 component vector and
this x being a rectangular matrix you cannot invert it. But on the other hand x transpose
x which is a k plus 1 cross k plus 1 matrix it might be invertible. So the transpose has
a very important role in regression analysis and many other applications.
And its symmetry also helps us a lot. Trace of a matrix. Trace of a matrix mathematically
means only the sum of the diagonal elements. But in terms of application what does it mean?
So say for example if I study the variation of more than one random variable such that
their variances are captured so say for example x1, x2, x3 and their variances variance of
x1 variance of x2 variance of x3. This part we have not defined so we are not going to
in discussion. But if we consider the sum of the diagonal elements that is the trace
and as an application if we study the dispersion matrix of a vector then so dispersion matrix
or the variance covariance matrix of a vector then the trace of that matrix is eventually
giving us the total variation of the entire system.
And that total variation of the system again you can see that it is interchangeable that
means variance of x1 plus x2 plus x3 it is the sum. So sum is commutative. So trace of
a is same as trace of a transpose not only that trace of a plus b equal to trace of b
plus a it is same as trace of a plus trace of b not even trace of a b equal to trace
of b a. So although the dimension of a b need not be the same of the dimension of b a but
still trace of a b equal to trace of b a let me give you one example which is very common
and very frequently used. So say for this very easy vector 1 vector column vector all
component 1 okay and what is 1 transpose 1 that means this is first this is a row vector
1, 1, 1, 1, 1 and then column vector 1, 1, 1, 1, 1 a trivial to see that it is n okay.
But so as n is a 1 cross 1 matrix right here if you consider this is a matrix it is 1 cross
1 matrix. So the trace of this quantity is nothing but same as n nothing special about
it. But you consider the other way round trace of 1 vector as a column vector 1 vector as
a row vector. Now if you do the multiplication you will get a matrix all component 1. Now
implement the definition of trace of 1 transpose 1 it is nothing but the sum of all diagonal
elements and that is n. So that is same as trace of 1 transpose 1 is a simple example
but it is a something which is striking and it has immense use in statistics and also
the data science. Doing many calculations become much more easier using this property
of the trace and many results become analytically interpretable.
So matrix inverse I have told you notice one thing most of them are just formula few remark
I want to make here. It is a process where A B inverse is B inverse A inverse provided
A and B both are invertible okay. That means both of them are square matrix and both of
them are having non-zero determinant okay. So determinant of A not equal to 0 determinant
of B not equal to 0 and they are square matrix definitely. On the other hand A B inverse is
B inverse A inverse it is sometime we call it as a socks and shoe law because when we
wear first we wear the socks and then we wear the shoe but when we do the reverse process
the remove then first we remove the shoe and then we remove the socks. So remember this
operational identity.
Next thing that I want to tell you that already I have told that when you have a block matrix
it is inverse will be very much applicable when you are trying to predict a vector given
another vector and there you need to use this formula for the computational ease I am not
going for the derivation or anything. The third one either the last one is a very important
has very important application because often the error computation or the evaluation of
the process is done in such a way which is often known as a jackknife method or live
one out method. Live one out method means you have a data set and you have want to fit
a model for the entire data set you want to cross check whether the fitted model is good
one or not for that what we do is first we remove one observation from the entire data
based on n minus 1 observation we fit the entire data and then whatever data we have
kept aside we predict the value of the data and cross check how much gap is happening.
The next step remove the second data do the entire calculation based on the n minus 1
data and again you predict the second data and cross check how much gap is happening
between the data. In that way you complete the entire set with n elements and end of
the day you will have a very nice assessment of how good the model fitting is and that
is often known the statistics it is known as the jackknife evaluation or it is popularly
known as the live one out method.
Now you see that if we go for this evaluation process it requires a huge computational
cost because based on n minus 1 observation you are fitting the same model or estimating
the parameters of the same model or learning the parameters of the same model again and
again and again. So it requires a huge cost in terms of space and time, memory and time
and that thing in linear regression analysis you can directly avoid that computation you
can completely avoid through this result.
So here if you have the entire matrix if you want to remove one column or one row so that
row and that row transpose will be coming here. So suppose in that structure it will
be x transpose x and the row that you are willing to remove may be the ith row and the
ith row transpose then the decomposition of this entire quantity inverse I think I have
made a mistake this should be inverse. So this quantity inverse will be this one.
So as a consequence whatever the recomputation process leaving one data out that will be
at your hand just knowing or fitting the entire model only once together for the all data
rest all computational outcome will be governed by this analysis. So it helps us to reduce
the cost and time a lot. So these mathematical expressions are very much useful for ease
of computation and the inversion formula is pretty easy that if whatever the matrix you
need to take the adjoints of them and divided by the determinant of the entire matrix and
as this quantity comes in the denominator you also need to maintain that the determinant
of A naught equals to 0 and that is how you get the inverse.
The challenge comes when theoretically it is determinant is not equal to 0 but computationally
the determinant is close to 0 very very close to 0 that definitely whatever elements you
are getting as an inverse they often gives us trouble and in statistics and mathematics
we have technique to deal with in statistics we call it a singular value decomposition.
In mathematics we call it singular value decomposition in statistics we have its application in terms
of PCA. So we will touch upon all those stuff.
So to do PCA or the singular value decomposition what we require we require the compute the
Eigen values of a square symmetric matrices or at least the square matrices we require.
The trace has a nice connection with the Eigen values the sum over diagonal element is same
of the Eigen values and the determinant of a matrix is the product of the Eigen values
and the power matrix directly transfer to the power of the Eigen values inverse of Eigen
of a matrix is Eigen values of the inverse of a matrix is 1 upon the Eigen values provided
none of them are 0. So it is trivially true but because any Eigen value is 0 that means
the determinant itself is 0 because the determinant of a matrix determinant of a matrix is nothing
but the product of the Eigen values. So if any Eigen value is 0 so product is 0 determinant
is 0 the matrix is not invertible if all of them are non-zero then definitely you have
this structure that the inverse of the Eigen inverted matrix as the Eigen value is same
as the reciprocal of the Eigen value. So here is a very nice toy example of computation
of Eigen value suppose a is a matrix it is a square matrix need not be a symmetric matrix
then the Eigen value of this matrix is nothing but the determinant of a minus lambda i. So
here it is 2 cross 2 matrix that determinant equals to 0 and this equation this is a equation
in lambda and this equation is known as the characteristic equation characteristic equation
to after solving this equation the solution of lambda we get is 5 and minus 2 here you
can give work it out it is very simple so 1 minus that means the determinant of this
matrix 1 minus lambda 2 minus lambda so 1 minus lambda into 2 minus lambda minus 4 into
3 equals to 0. So this is the characteristic equation we call it q lambda then 4 into 3
so maybe I should ok so that is good. So now you solve it and you solve after solving
this you will be getting the solution and after getting the solution we need to reconstruct
the equation that means in the form of first you focus here that suppose if we take lambda
equal to 5 then 1 minus lambda becomes minus 4 and 2 minus lambda becomes minus 3.
So 4 minus 4 3 minus 3 and x that equals to 0 so it row sum equal to 0 column sum equal
to 0. So to take the row sum we just need sorry this row sum is 0 the first row sum
is 0 second row sum is 0 so for that I just need a vector 1 1 you have already seen the
example that if you need to take the sum of a vector you just need to use the vector 1
1 1 each and you do the dot product it will give you this.
Similarly if you use lambda equal to minus 2 you will get this set of equation and if
you want to solve them so 3 4 4 3 just similar magnitude with opposite sign so minus 4 3
I think that is that is 1 will be good enough for having the other value of the eigenvector.
Now what is the importance so this eigenvalue and eigenvector here it tries to say that
for this matrix we have 2 associated eigenvectors which one is this one another is this one
such that if I multiply this matrix with this vector then it is equivalent to multiply
this vector with this eigenvalue. So in the multiplication of this vector by this matrix
is same as multiplying so you see that 1 4 3 2 1 4 3 2 this is the matrix multiply with
one of the eigenvector which is 1 1 which is coming as 1 4 multiply it is 5 5 which
is eventually 5 times 1 1 so multiplying this vector by a matrix is same as multiplying
the same vector with a constant lambda. So matrix multiplication eventually becomes a
equivalent to a constant multiplication and when that thing happens then that vector is
the eigenvector of that matrix and the associated value is the eigenvalue of that vector. So
this is how geometrically the interpretation of eigenvalue and eigenvector is. The application
is definitely the well studied principal component analysis regression analysis okay gradually
we will talk about that.
So principal component analysis what we do is that when we have a huge amount of data
or variables like you can consider the handwritten image classification problem or the iris data
that we have in many software the built-in data that setosa, varsical or virginica these
three categories and petal length, petal width, seper length, seper width all these variables
are present. So all four variables need not be important for classification purpose or
prediction purpose. So we can do a principal component analysis like this we can construct
the matrix X transpose X or the variance covariance matrix and from there we can calculate the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors. So just to give a sketch may be later on so eigenvectors lambda
1 greater than lambda 2 greater than lambda 3 so on and so forth lambda k is greater than
equals to 0 we are not preferred and corresponding to lambda 1 the eigenvector is V1 corresponding
lambda 2 eigenvector is V3 so on and so V2 so on and so forth.
Now we need to stop somewhere the stopping rule we will discuss later on we will not
consider all of them but some of them we will consider and the data will be projected on
all these eigenvectors or eigendirections. So X dot product with this eigenvector so
this is the score one then again X vector projected or the eigendirection that is S2.
So in this way you will get another vector for data X and that you can do for each X
as a consequence what you will get is nothing but a matrix calculated by all these vectors
V1 V2 up to V say M as many you want to incorporate and here you have the entire data matrix.
So matrix multiplication with this one you will get another set of feature vectors which
is of lesser dimension but important information will be captured there. So as you can understand
that the variable selection matrix multiplication and through eigenvalue identifications all
these things are important for data analysis part. So when you will do hands on you will
be able to connect all those stuff very easily projection is another thing which is the generalized
notion of regression we let me see how much content I have left with so we can cover.
So projection means in physics perspective or geometry perspective suppose I have a vector
here and I have this XY plane and consider another vector which I if you will be nice
if I have certain color maybe this is the color. Suppose this is a vector I have and
I want to project this vector on XY plane so that means eventually I am looking in this
way that I have a light source here which is projecting this arrow on this XY plane.
And that means the shadow is falling on this XY plane and if the shadow is falling in this
XY plane now suppose this is a new object on the XY plane what will be the shadow of
the shadow it will be nothing but itself it will be nothing but itself. So if you have
a free vector in the entire large space its projection in a smaller subspace will bring
that vector in that smaller subspace but if you are in that smaller subspace if you consider
the projection on that subspace you will get the same vector itself.
So the that operation this projection operation we can do with a matrix multiplication very
easily and this matrix multiplication this suppose this will give some vector v and and
that suppose this is z vector and we get this v vector but again p of v is again v and that
is true for all z because p of v means p of p of z equal to v and that is true for all
z that means p of z equal to v p of z equal to v p of v equal to v so p square v equal
to oh sorry just a second okay so sorry and v v is nothing but p of z okay.
So this is the thing happening and that is happening for all z as a consequence we have
the identity p square equal to p the projection matrix always satisfies this identity and
this feature is known as p is an idempotent matrix and if p is an idempotent matrix then
one identity minus p is also idempotent matrix the trace idempotent matrix has Eigen values
either 0 or 1 so the trace computation of that idempotent matrix becomes much more
easier in that scenario and the entire regression is nothing but a game of projection okay.
So whatever you do the regression analysis is a projection of that data the response
variable y in the regress in the space of the regressor variable we cannot go beyond
that whatever we want to do okay so that is how they are connected with each other.
Now let us consider few more things which are important so already we have considered
about the dot product and in more sophisticated technical aspect we call it inner product
people often write in this way sorry a b does not matter so in for real value vector it
is a transpose b that is sum over a i p i. Now if you consider a transpose a that is
sum over a i square but here what you can see that it is the Euclidean distance from
0 vector to this a any component a so if you have this the length square is nothing but
this quantity.
Now notice that always this measure of distance might not be useful for us okay we need to
consider more generalized version of notion of error which typically want to use the scale
adjustment okay and sometimes make it unit free. Here notice that sum over a i square
a transpose a that thing hypothetically I can write a vector transpose identity vector
identity matrix a vector I hope all of you will agree with it. But this identity is very
nice to deal with but it may not consider all the necessary information suppose each
of the component of ai's have different scaling and that scaling is giving us impact so one
measurement in kilometer and another measurement is micrometer okay suppose a has two component
a 1 and a 2 one measurement is in kilometer another measurement is in micrometer.
So if we consider sum over a i square only the observation in terms of kilometer that
will lead to the conclusion the impact of the micrometer might not be so impactful.
So say for example the change in a parts of a vehicle that change has happened a little
bit change and it is affecting in kilometer the mileage okay so as a consequence the if
we want to have a combined impact or combined variation if I go by this measurement it will
be always driven by the kilometer but the root cause of the change is the change happened
in the parts and that is more important that thing is not reflecting here.
So if I can have a matrix m which is scaling down these two things say for example m if
I consider say 1 upon say sigma 1 square 1 upon sigma 2 square which is which could
be the scaling factor then if I use a transpose m a vector which will be nothing but using
this formula a transpose m a equal to a i a i a j m i j which is nothing but say a 1
square by sigma 1 square plus a 2 square by sigma 2 square.
Now you can see that the scaling has been adjusted for both of the variable they have
now a reasonable impact on the final conclusion not only that if here I have assumed that
these two quantities are 0 if they are non-zero quantity then also this general expression
will be able to help us so for that we need a matrix m which is symmetric that means m
transpose equal to m and determinant of m is greater than 0 if I replace this identity
matrix with a matrix m like this then I can still have a reasonable notion of the distance
and this structure is known as the quadratic form why it is quadratic form consider that
this m i j are the coefficient and a i a j they are variable each a i and a j has power
1 so in this expression all component has power 2 this is power 1 this is power 1 so
all component has power 2 that is why it is known as a quadratic form.
Well based on the quadratic form we can also obtain the maximum eigenvalue or the minimum
eigenvalue it has again application on the PCA and normalization of the data in ridge
regression lasso regression all those types you will be able to see and finally we have
the data and we do the rotation through a matrix or a transformation with a matrix which
has the particular property such that its columns are orthonormal to each other and
that one is giving a transpose equal to a inverse leading to a transpose a transpose
equal to a transpose a equal to identity. Now if you take the determinant of a transpose
which is same as the determinant of a determinant of a transpose and equal to the determinant
of identity which is 1 now determinant of a and a transpose they are same so determinant
of a square equal to 1 as a consequence determinant of a is either plus or minus so this one is
an impact of I mean of a situation where it preserves the square norm.
That means if you consider the norm in this form the square distance that is preserved
with this transformation which is often important technically it is known as an isometric transformation
but for simplicity you can in terms of Euclidean norm. So Euclidean norm on the square norm
is preserved through this orthogonal transformation and the advantage or you can see this is a
rotation matrix any object we have you can rotate the so any object you have you can
rotate the object with angle theta entire object for that purpose this you can use this matrix
but again more generally for this idempotent sorry this orthogonal matrix what as it is
preserving the norm so distance between any two point on this body rigid body the distance
remains same. So as a general perspective for the rigid
body transformation you can use this rotation matrix in statistics or data science we have
its application through PCA because when we do PCA we get a rotation of the entire data
with the data driven coordinate system and then we do the projection so whatever eigenvectors
that we have discussed so far for this principle this one I hope I have done here.
So this one this V1 V2 Vk if based on that whatever matrix if we can construct based
on all these vectors V1 V2 Vk they will construct an orthogonal matrix and rest of the job will
become much more easier because it will give us uncorrelated variables.
I think with that and this is few not even calculation help such that you can do the
matrix differentiation and it has huge application to the optimization problem if you go do
the gradient descent if you do the least square whatever you want to do you need to do the
vector differentiation so you can make use all of them.
I think with that note I should stop here if you have any query I will be happy to take
the questions and based on your feedback and all those stuff we will go for. So you can
see my home page for few I think it is not clear few books suggestions are given there
in the front page and if you have so one book I am definitely suggesting David C. Lay linear
algebra and its application. So it is a very nice book easy reading book without any help
of any instructor with very nice diagrams and applications.
So anybody and everybody can read this one and few statistics books are also suggested
there Miller and Miller will be a good one to start with without any background. So if
you want and the probability lecture note is also there so you can have a look there.
Rest now let us have some questions if we have can numerically countable data set be
a numerical countable data be function as well. Yes of course because the countable data
is a function of the input of the random variable.
So here we consider the random variable as I have told that the person we choose and
the number of sibling the person has. So this number is a random number the person has associated
with. So the input is the person information the output is the number of siblings. So definitely
it is a function of which input is the identity of that person the output is the number of
sibling of that person. So in that case it is definitely a function.
Will there be any possibility that the data can be classified as a combination of categorical
and numeric. Yes of course there are situations where the variables are categorical as well
as numerical and in that case we can still do the classification problem. I think the
question data can be classified as combination of categorical and numerical. Well some component
can be categorical some component can be numerical of course and if you have those type of situation
where you have category and the categories are measured by numerical then that is a very
easy example of nominal data sorry ordinal data.
And most of the cases we do Poisson regression type of analysis for those types. What is
the difference between the random vector or feature vector. So well the random vector
is definitely from a perspective of little bit more theoretical aspect. The random vector
means a vector valued outcome of a single input in the construction of the random variable.
Feature vector is the realized value of the random vector used for the further data analysis.
So eventually the random vector is used as a feature vector for the further data analysis.
Random vector is a theoretical object. Feature vector is the realized value of the random
vector. Why should we consider the square error, not cube error or any other power.
Can I have the screen once again. So why we are using square error instead of cube error.
The thing is square error always have a Euclidean notion is useful. So eventually the error notion
is norm. I mean first we have the difference x and y. Then it is absolute value and then
it is power. So power could be 1, power could be 2, power could be 3. So if they are vector
it is x minus y vector. So this is another vector. Take term by term absolute value.
Then if the absolute value power 1 that is usually known as L1 norm, L2 norm. So L1 norm
is sum over xi minus yi i running from 1 to n. It is also known as a taxi cab distance
like this or going like this. It is known as a taxi cab distance. Either you go from
here in this way or you go directly here and go there or it is also known as a Manhattan
distance. L2 norm is eventually going by the radius. So this is x1 y1, this is x2 y2.
So the x1 minus x2 square plus y1 minus y2 square root of that and that is L2 norm.
Now you can make it general for any in functional analysis usually it is given as an LP norm.
So you can have x minus y their absolute value after that power p or often they write in
the topic. So they write in this way LP norm. So any power you can use but remember first
you take the absolute distance and then take the power. If you do not take the absolute
distance there will be positive negative component and if you raise by the power or by an odd
number then the sign will have an impact you will not get a proper notion of the distance.
What is the real application and reason for finding the skewness or interquartile distance
or peakness or cutoff. So the skewness means say for example the tilt of the distribution
either it is have a longer tail to the larger value or the longer tail to the less value
and if that tilt is present in the data we need not or not prefer to go by the mean.
Mean in that case the if the data is upward bias mean will not be always be pulled by
the upward bias the central part of the data will not be well represented by the mean.
So to deal with the data which have positive or negative skewness we will prefer to go
by its different quantities not by the mean in that case. So skewness and skewness measure
gives us that warning that we should not always go by the mean in that case. Interquartile
distance is all another application because in interquartile distance is a distribution
free measurement for measuring skewness and kurtosis skewness also can be captured by
the quartile. This measurement theoretically assumes that the moments are finite like mean
median variance and all other higher order moment they are finite but interquartile distance
is a distribution free measure for any distribution you can make use of that.
So this is more like non parametric structure and skewness as I have told that the skewness
keeps the assurity that if the skewness is very high then the very very high then the
data will almost behave like a constant compared to the other values which have very less
skewness okay. So skewness less means we have to be careful and take care of its scaling
and the variation more I mean more seriously than the skewness if the skewness is high
you be relaxed with that part of the data but if the skewness is low you have to be
very much careful and incorporating all details of that part of the data in a thoroughly and
properly in your analysis that is the ground level indication from the measurement of skewness
okay. Thank you.